j'en ai vraiment assez c'est toujours
pareil personne ne me croit voyons
casimir arrête de bouder apprend à être
beau joueur
ce n'est pas parce que tu m'as fait une
farce qui n'a pas marché tu dois faire
ça tu es tu là n'ont pas bien avec moi
tu verras non je ne marche pas j'ai trop
de travail
tiens si je reçois d'y arriver c'est à
phares sont près de lui
non pas ce n'est pas une farce bonjour
je les salue françois jean casimir
casimir jeter guy bonjour il boude
mais non je ne veux pas mais j'y m'agace
parce qu'elle ne veut pas me croire au
monde pour casimir et tout cas ce que
julie ne crois pas elle ne croit pas
comme on notera finalement envoyé une
voiture et il ne te crois pas non je
suis d' absurde de julie et l'autre jour
nous l'avons vu ensemble
casimir s'amuser avec dans le fond du
jardin et même je t'avais fait appeler
l'ambulance qui ne t'en souviens pas je
me rappelle parfaitement sans relâche
pas mais il ne s'agit pas d'un jouet
mais d'une véritable voiture
oui oui une vraie voiture
oui et alors écoute casimir l'autre jour
du nous a déjà fait le coup tu quand tu
révises est ont permis de conduire c'est
un cadeau dans mon oncle archibald
mais oui mais oui mais oui mais je peux
déjà montré je te répète notre jeu c'est
bien elle est super mais malheureusement
elle est grande comme ça alors je vous
propose gentiment veut faire un tour en
voiture et vous voulez pas me croire
et bien tant pis pour finir tu voulais
faire et où voter et bien je vous emmène
tous les enfants venez vite dans quelle
pointure
je vous emmène faire un tour en voiture
grâce à mon bon magique quand julie puis
jetant traiter le volant qui est dans
ton coeur c'est que je t'emmène que
c'est vrai quelle bonne idée je ne
savais pas que c'était un kiosque au
volant installé nous les enfants
je lis mon talent avant oui mais c'est
pas une voiture étant à 0 contact soit
prudent
t'inquiète pas julie se fera une brève
incluant la nous quittons le jardin de
l'îlot ensemble ouais non aujourd'hui
regardés comme la campagne est belle
fetter bon je suis agent facteurs en
voiture puis quand j'ai dit tu as vu la
tête qu'il a fait en nous voyant dans
une aussi belle voix terre attention
j'ai tourné à gauche notamment
enfin maintenant je tourne à droite
et voilà la route redevient droite ça
ira beaucoup mieux
garder les enfants une voiture toute
blanche avec une lumière bleue qui
clignotent sur le toit alors vous savez
ce que c'est ces turbulences
attention françois elle va couper la
route les enfants vous croyez que je
dois la laisser passer
et pourquoi ambulance il peut y avoir
quelqu'un de très malade il faut la
laisser patient doit toujours laissé
passer une ambulance
continuera t voilà maintenant une
voiture tout rouge avec des tuyaux
partout et une lumière orange qui
clignotent sur le toit qu'est ce que
c'est les enfants
c'est les pompiers ils ont l'air pressé
oui c'est normal
[Musique]
j'ai une voiture on sait qu'ici mire
mais oui asie
sa lola laquelle edberg il est vrai
qu'une nuit pour la trouver je ne sais
pas comment j'ai vu c'est chrome
voilà je vous avais fait mon grand frère
adoré les bêtes à manger où la demande
est là à lesparre vite montée - on s'en
fout tu es mon âge et d'aller vous quasi
mieux tu nous emmènes ou si oui écouter
mes amis je suis désolé mais je crois
qu'il n'y a plus de place à fermer les
portes hier à ces patchs s'écouter
remonter dans votre voiture et nous
ferons la course à attention départ on y
va
15 min